well good afternoon
yesterday vladimir putin recognized two
regions of ukraine as independent states
and he bizarrely asserted that these
regions are no longer part of ukraine
and their sovereign territory
to put it simply russia just announced
that it is carving out a big chunk of
ukraine
last night putin authorized russian
forces to deploy into the region these
regions
today he asserted that these regions are
actually
extend deeper than the two
areas he recognized claiming large areas
currently under the jurisdiction of the
ukraine government
he's setting up a rationale to take more
territory by force in my view
and if we listened to a speech last
night and many of you did i know
he's uh he's setting up a rationale to
go much further
this is the beginning of a russian
invasion of ukraine as he indicated and
asked permission to be able to do from
his duma
so let's begin to uh so i i'm going to
begin to impose sanctions in response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014.
and if russia goes further with this
invasion we stand prepared to go further
as with sanctions
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives them the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law
and demands a firm response from the
international community
over the last few months we've
coordinated closely with our nato allies
and partners in europe and around the
world to prepare that response
we've settled along and i've told putin
to his face some a month more than a
month ago
that we would act together
and the moment russia moved against
ukraine
russia has now undeniably moved against
ukraine by declaring these independent
states
so today i'm announcing the first
tranche of sanctions to impose cost on
russia in response to their actions
yesterday
these have been closely coordinated with
our allies and partners and will
continue to escalate sanctions if russia
escalates
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government
from western financing it can no longer
raise money from the west and cannot
trade in its new debt on our markets or
european markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead will also impose sanctions on
russia's elites and their family members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
and because of russian's actions we've
worked with germany to ensure nordstream
2
will not as i promised will not move
forward
as russia contemplates its next move we
have our next move prepared as well
russia will pay an even steeper price if
it continues its aggression including
additional sanctions
the united states will continue to
provide defensive assistance to ukraine
in the meantime and will continue to
reinforce and reassure our nato allies
today in response to russian's admission
that it will not withdraw its forces
from belarus i have authorized
additional movements of u.s forces and
equipment
already stationed in europe to
strengthen our baltic allies estonia
latvia and lithuania
let me be clear
these are totally defensive moves on our
part
we have no intention of fighting russia
we want to send an unmistakable message
though that the united states together
with our allies will defend every inch
of nato territory
and abide by
the commitments we made to nato we still
believe that russia is poised to go much
further in launching a massive military
attack against ukraine
hope i'm wrong about that hope we're
wrong about that but russia has only
escalated its threat against the rest of
ukrainian territory including major
cities and including the capital city of
kyiv
there are there are still well over 150
000 russian troops surrounding ukraine
and as i said
russian forces remain positioned in
belarus to attack ukraine from the north
including warplanes and offensive
missile systems
russia has moved troops closer to
ukraine's border with russia
russia's naval vessels are maneuvering
in the black sea to ukraine south
including amphibious assault ships
missile cruisers and submarines
russia has moved supplies of blood and
medical equipment into position on their
border
you don't need blood unless you plan on
starting a war
over the last few days we've seen much
of the playbook that secretary blinken
laid out
last week in the united nations security
council come to pass
a major increase in military
provocations and false flag events along
the line of contact in the donbas
dramatically staged conveniently on
camera meeting of putin's security
council to grandstand for the russian
public
and now political provocation of
recognizing sovereign ukrainian
territory as so-called independent re
republics in clear violation again of
international law
president putin assault authorization
from the russian parliament to use
military force outside of russian
territory and this set the stage for
further pretext of further provocations
by russia to try to justify further
military action
none of us none of us should be fooled
none of us will be fooled there is no
justification
further russian assault in ukraine
remains a severe threat in the days
ahead
and if russia proceeds it is russia and
russia alone that bears the
responsibility
as we respond my administration is using
every tool at our disposal to protect
american businesses and consumers from
rising prices at the pump
as i said last week
defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that
but as we will do but as we do this
i'm going to take robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at a russian economy not ours
we're closely monitoring energy supplies
for any disruption
we're executing the plan in coordination
with major oil producing consumers and
producers toward a collective investment
to secure stability and global energy
supplies
this will be this will blunt gas prices
i want to limit the pain to the american
people our feeling at the gas pump
this is critical to me
in the last few days i've been in
constant contact with european leaders
including with ukrainian president
zielinski
vice president harris met in person with
the leaders in germany over the weekend
and at the munich conference including
president zielinski
at every step we have shown the united
states and our allies and partners are
working in unison
which he hasn't been counting on mr
putin we're united in our support of
ukraine
we are united in our opposition to
russian aggression
and we're united in our resolve to
defend our nato alliance
and we're united in our understanding of
the urgency and seriousness of the
threat russia is making to global peace
and stability
yesterday
the world heard clearly
the full extent of vladimir putin's
twisted rewrite of history
going back more than a century as he
waxed eloquently
noting
that well i'm not going to go into it
but nothing in putin's length of remarks
indicate any interest in pursuing real
dialogue on european security in the
year 2022
he directly attacked ukraine's right to
exist
he indirectly threatened territorial
formerly held by russia
including nations that today are
thriving democracies and members of nato
he explicitly threatened war unless his
extreme demands were met
and there is no question
that russia is the aggression
so we're clear-eyed about the challenges
we're facing nonetheless
there is still time to avert the worst
case scenario that will bring untold
suffering to millions of people if they
move as suggested
the united states and our allies and
partners remain open to diplomacy if it
is serious
when all is said and done
we're going to judge russia by its
actions not its words
and whatever russia does next we're
ready to respond with unity
clarity and conviction
we'll probably have more to say about
this as
it moves on i'm hoping diplomacy is
still available thank you all very much
[Music]
are you still open to music